Normand Grondin.
parlé de science-fiction,
aujourd'hui, c'est la réalité :
on a réussi à greffer
vendredi
de porc à un être humain,
et cinq et cinq jours plus tard,
le patient est toujours en vie.
David Benett, un américain
de 57 ans, avait épuisé toutes
les autres possibilitéss. En de,
il a accepté d'être le cob
de cette première mondiale.
L'équipe de chirugien
de l'Université du Maryland
a pratiqué ce qu'on appelleune :
la transplantationne
animal à un humain.
Le coeur du porc,
pas atteint sa maturité,
a été motiquement
pour que l'organe cesse de
se dével
pour diminuer le risque
de rejet par le patient.tient.t.
C'est un véritable tour de force
sur le plan scientifique., chirn
cardiaque, CHUM
- C'est une grande percée
scientifique, on ne peut pas
de modifier génétiquement
pour rendre les tissus
comme invisibles au système
immunitaire des hue première en,
une première scientifique.
- L'intervention s'est déroulée
sans complications majeures
complétée, le nouveau coeurdu pe
normalement dans sa poitrine.
- C'est recevoir plein de médics
antirejet comme on le fait
à l'occasion pour des
transplantations normales,
une première et puis on suit ça
avec grand intérêt.
- L'objectif de l'équipe
de pallier au manque criant
d'organes disponibles pourles pr
les très nombreuses demandes
de transplantation, partout
Si on réussi à transplanter
un coeur de porc avec succès,
tous les espoirs pourraient
La toute première xénogreffe
de coeur a eu lieu au début
enfant, Baby Faye, qui a reçu
l'organeate,ate,ate,ate,ate,ate,
avant de le rejeter,
21 jours plus tard.
Ici Normand Grondin,
anada, Mon